there are at least a few thousand people
here all of them
uh from the public sector and with one
common cause they are calling for uh pay
rise they want a better deal from the
government i have two social care
workers here with me from birmingham we
have patricia annavon thank you for
joining us and talking to us patricia
we'll start with you just tell me how
hard it's been for you it's been very
difficult you have to juggle with two
jobs i'm a lecturer i look after my
daughter who is not we have got mental
health issues
it is hard we demand better pay we
demand better sick pay we demand better
for our children we are tired of being
lied to we are tired with the government
that lie to us constantly we demand we
deserve better we demand better pay we
demand sick pay that's why we are here
today
all the workers in england they deserve
better because they work
very hard thank you
yvonne uh just give me a sense of you
know you're also a social care worker
you don't get paid very much do you so
how hard has it been for you with
everything going up and the fact that
you weren't during the pandemic
it's very hard sometimes you look on
your gas and you're electric and you
started to cry because you don't know
which one to top up first you can't go
without hider but you have to find a way
to do it you have to be working 50 60
hours so you're able to meet your bills
and pay your rent this is not acceptable
in today the 21st century this story
government needs to do something for
care workers we deserve better we have
worked through the pandemic all through
the pandemic and we did not even get a
recognition from our provider to say
thank you for your hard work that you
have done it's not acceptable we deserve
better and that's the reason why we are
here today we need to be able to pay our
bills and live comfortably
and you heard today that the treasury
chief secretary to the treasury simon
clark has said that public sector
workers shouldn't have unrealistic
expectations over pay rises because of
the potential
effect that it could have on pushing up
inflation what do you
think what do you feel when you hear
that
that's really upsetting it is very
upsetting they can have their own pay
rise and everybody else who works hard
cannot have pay rise that has got to
stop everybody needs a pay rise care
workers needs 15 pounds an hour because
they work so hard looking after somebody
who is vulnerable it's not funny it's
not easy this has got to stop we need
pay rise we need better working
conditions thank you
he can sit where he's sitting and he's
sitting comfortably he's driving a posh
car and i'm walking and i'm taking the
bus to work and i'm trying to get taxi
to work so you cannot stay up there and
tell me what i am facing down here what
i deserve what i need so he can stay
there and talk what he's talking because
he's talking nonsense because he's
living comfortable his family i can
assure you are going to private schools
and everything while we have to send our
kids to secondary school and grammar
school enough is enough so you can stay
there and talk he doesn't even
understand what's going on down here he
needs to get up off his eye us come down
here and realize what we are going
through we are the real people so he
needs to come down here and see what we
are going through then you can talk you
can't talk at the moment